a Big Bang occurred when Chachi BT was
released the first widely available
computer program the average person
could talk to as if it were another
human beating the touring test and doing
things most agreed myself included was
not possible when I started this series
4 years ago the richness or infinite
potential that language offers is why
many experts in linguistics and
computation strongly believed computers
would never come close to understanding
human language many of them have now
changed their mind if I were to take an
hour in doing something the chat GPT 4
might take 1 second it's quite
terrifying it felt as if not only are my
belief systems collapsing but it feels
as if the entire human race is going to
be eclipsed and left in the dust soon
what happened so far in this series
we've covered the last few Decades of
neural network research focused on
narrow problems with a fixed goal where
people trained an artificial neural
network on one task with a big database
of example inputs and outputs to learn
from known as supervised learning in
this case the learning signal was the
difference between the guess and the
correct answer this led to neural
networks that could do one kind of thing
really well such as classify images
detect spam or predict your next YouTube
video but each network was like a silo
and left no clear road to more general
purpose
systems you can think of these siloed
networks as modeling intuition only but
not reasoning because reasoning involves
a chain of thoughts it's a sequential
process and so to crack open this
problem of making neural networks more
general purpose we first needed to train
neural networks to talk looking back we
can see the origin of this kind of
experiment ation in the mid 80s one
inspired paper in 1986 by Jordan trained
a neural network to learn sequential
patterns in his initial experiments he
trained a Tiny Network with only a
handful of neurons to predict simple
sequences of two symbols and to give the
network memory he borrowed from how we
think our minds work which is to have an
ongoing state of mind which helps us
decide our next action given what we
currently observe he added a set of
memory neurons he called state units to
the side of the network and added
connections from the output to the state
units and then the state units were
connected to the middle of the network
and finally also connected to themselves
this resulted in a state of mind which
depended on the past and could affect
the future what he called a recurrent
neural network another key Innovation
was how he set up a prediction problem
for the network to learn he trained a
network by simply hiding the next letter
in a sequence with this approach the
learning signal is the difference
between the Network's guess of the next
symbol and the true data and critically
after training it he set up the network
to generate data by connecting the
output of the network back on itself and
kicking it off with a single letter
after which it would generate the
pattern it learned and he observed the
network would make mistakes but those
mistakes would go away after being
trained on the pattern more and he
noticed the learned sequences were not
just memorized they were
generalized in another experiment he
trained a network on a spatial pattern
after training a network on the sequence
he fed in a point and plotted the
results and it would correctly continue
the cyclical pattern however when he
tried to start it on a new Point outside
the path it had learned the network
would follow the same cycle pattern but
from a different position at a different
scale and gradually would return back to
the stable sequence he writes when a
network learns to perform a sequence it
essentially learns to follow a
trajectory through State space and these
learned trajectories tend to be
attractors borrowing a term from chaos
theory he viewed an attractor as the
generalized pattern learned by the
network which was represented in the
connection weights in the inner
layers 5 years later another researcher
Jeffrey Elman picked up on Jordan
research and did the same thing with a
slightly bigger network with 50 neurons
and trained it on language at first he
used 200 short sentences he created
interestingly he didn't provide any word
boundaries he just simply applied a
stream of letters to the network 10
times and at each step trained it to get
closer at making the correct prediction
of the next
letter the first interesting thing he
noticed was that the network learned
word boundaries on its own own he shows
this in a plot where at the onset of a
new word the chance of error or
uncertainty is high and as more of the
word is received the error rate declines
since the sequence is increasingly
predictable at the end of the word the
error would jump back up again but not
as high as before this reflects what we
saw in information Theory where an
intelligent signal contain decreasing
entropy over sequence length he then
notes that it's worth looking into
whether the network has has any
understanding of the meaning behind
these words he probed the internal
neurons in the context unit as it was
processing words and then he plotted
them and compared the spatial
Arrangement what he found was the
network would spatially cluster words
based on meaning for example it
separated nouns which are inanimate and
animate and Within These groups he saw
subcategorization animate objects were
broken down into human and non-human
clusters inanimate objects were broken
down down into breakable and edible
clusters and so he emphasizes that the
network was learning these hierarchical
interpretations but Elman notes that
according to Nome Chomsky this shouldn't
be possible how could a little Network
understand the word semantically but
Elman argued his experiments showed
otherwise everything could be learned
from patterns in the language this
approach to training neural networks by
hiding the next event closely aligns
with how humans learn he referenced an
idea that preverbal children be begin
the process of language acquisition by
listening and talking along in their
mind with a speaker always guessing the
next word and they can learn from these
internal
mistakes he also had a fascinating
Insight since we can represent words as
points in high dimensional space then
sequences of words or sentences can be
thought of as a pathway and similar
sentences seem to follow similar
Pathways our thought follows a pathway
it's useful to pause and consider your
own mind is often on a pathway of
thought at many levels but still these
networks were small and seen as toy
problems and so for well over a decade
none of this research on language models
saw the light of day it really wasn't
until 2011 when an important Confluence
of researchers pushed this specific
experiment ahead interestingly was the
mundane sound ing application they
mentioned this is an important problem
because better character level
prediction could improve compression of
text files more speculatively achieving
the limit in text compression requires
an understanding that is equivalent to
intelligence this is in line with one
theory that biological brains at their
core are prediction machines and so if
we think of intelligence as the ability
to learn this views learning as the
compression of experience into a
predictive model of the world I'll see
you every second for the next hour or
what have you each each look at you is a
little bit different I don't store all
those second byc images I don't store
3,000 images I somehow compact this
information in this paper they trained a
much larger network with thousands of
neurons this time and millions of
connections to do next letter prediction
as early researchers had done after
training they had the models generate
Language by feeding their output back
into the input and kicking off the
process with some starting text for
example they gave the prompt the meaning
of life is and the network responded the
tradition of the ancient human
reproduction but beyond a few words the
pathway of thought fell off course and
veered into the nonsensical and so
clearly learning was happening but they
were hitting the capacity of the network
to maintain coherent context over long
sequences at the end of the paper they
claimed that if we could train a much
bigger network with millions of neurons
and billions of connections it is
possible that Brute Force alone would be
sufficient to achieve even higher
standards of performance and still few
took this line of research seriously
probably due to the mistakes but a
dedicated few pushed this effort ahead
another key figure is Andre karpathy he
did the same experiment again but this
time on a bigger Network work with more
layers and his results were even better
more plausible notably he trained them
on all of Shakespeare and noted that I
can barely recognize these from actual
Shakespeare and when he trained them on
mathematics papers he said you get
plausible looking math it's quite
astonishing and just like early
researchers he noticed how it learned in
phases and he writes what's beautiful
about this is we didn't have to hardcode
any of it the network decided what was
useful to keep track of this is one of
the cleanest and most compelling
examples of where the power in deep
learning is coming from and so this was
more evidence of setting up a system
with a broad goal of learning to speak
could then be retasked on arbitrary
narrow goals we might simply ask of it a
turning point came in 2017 when a team
of researchers at a lab called open AI
built on Kathy's work and set up a
larger recurrent Network and trained in
on a massive set of 82 million Amazon
reviews the largest model to date and
when they probed the neurons in this
network they found neurons deeper in the
network which had learned complex
conceptual concepts for example they
reported the discovery of a sentiment
neuron which was a single neuron within
the network that directly corresponded
to the sentiment of the text how
positive or negative it sounded they
showed this neuron's activation as it
processed text perfectly classifying the
sentiment this was striking because at
the time this was something industry
used commonly and required specialized
systems trained on that one task but in
this case they didn't do any of that
work the sentiment neuron emerged out of
the process of learning to predict the
next word and to show that this network
had a good internal model or
understanding of sentiment they had the
network generate text and while doing so
they forced that sentiment neuron to be
positive or negative and then it spit
out positive and negative reviews which
were entirely artificial but
indistinguishable from a human written
review and they write it is an open
question why our model recovers the
concept of sentiment in such a precise
disentangled interpretable and
manipulable way and this was just one
neuron in the Network full of these
representations of abstract Concepts it
learned from that data as a result of
trying to predict it for future
directions for their work they mentioned
the next key step which was Data
diversity but simply going bigger this
time was hitting a practical limit
because because there is a key problem
with recurrent neural networks because
they process data serially all the
contexts had to be squeezed into a fixed
internal memory and this was a
bottleneck limiting the ability of the
network to handle context over long
sequences of text and so meaning gets
squeezed out practically it was apparent
when generating long enough statements
with a recurrent neurl Network it might
make sense for a while but after a few
sentences it would always drift off into
gibberish Lear ing these long range
dependencies was a key challenge faced
by the
field an alternative approach to
recurrent neural networks tried to
tackle this problem by simply processing
the entire input sequence of text in
parallel but this requires many layers
of depth in order to compensate for the
lack of memory this approach is tempting
but the resulting Network becomes
impossible to train but also in 2017
another groundbreaking paper came out
with which was focused on the problem of
translating between languages and
offered a solution to this memory
constraint attention the key Insight
behind their approach was to create a
network with a new kind of dynamic layer
which could adapt some of its connection
weights based on the context of the
input known as a self attention layer
this allowed it to do in one layer which
traditional networks would have needed
several layers to accomplish this leads
to a shallower but wider Network that
was practical to train these self
attention layers work by allowing every
word in the input to look at and compare
itself to every other word and absorb
the meaning from the most relevant words
to better capture the context of its
intended use in that sentence and this
is done with the addition of attention
heads which are many networks inside the
layer acting as a kind of lens which
words can use to examine other words and
this is done by simply measuring the
distance between all the word pairs in
concept space similar Concepts will be
closer in this space leading to a higher
connection waiting consider the sentence
the river has a steep Bank in the self-
attention layer the word bank would
compare itself to every other word to
find conceptual similarities for example
the word River and Bank are both related
in the context of river bank and so this
would lead to a higher waiting in that
context this leads to a second operation
where each word absorbs meaning from
their connections based on the strength
of the waiting this allows the word to
adjust its representation or meaning to
push towards the concept or direction of
a riverbank and as we go through the
network we're going to make the
embedding vectors for a word get better
and better because they're going to take
into account more and more contextual
information and that's why we call them
Transformers they take each word and
transform their meaning shaped by the
words around
it to get a sense of this inaction let's
look at how a Transformer Network
generates music by predicting the next
note in this visualization each colored
line is a different attention head and
the weight of the line is the amount of
attention it gives to each location
notice each attention head looks for
different kinds of patterns in the music
the more attention heads you give a
network the more powerful it becomes and
notice that to select the next note at
each step all patterns are taken into
consider duration this is a network
architecture that can look at everything
everywhere all at once no internal
memory is needed its memory is replaced
by self- reference within the
layer but critically the attention is
all you need paper was still one foot in
the old Paradigm which was a narrow
Focus only on the problem of translation
trained in a supervised way they were
not after a general purpose system which
could do anything you asked it but
researchers at open AI saw this result
and immediately tried this more powerful
Transformer architecture on the exact
same next word prediction problem now at
a larger scale not before possible the
next year they published a paper which
introduced a model called GPT and this
time they had a much larger Network that
could capture hundreds of words of input
or context at a time it had multiple
layers each with self attention followed
by a fully connected layer and this time
they trained the Network on 7,000 books
from a variety of domains the results
were exciting if you prompted this
network with a segment of text it would
continue that passage much more
coherently than before but more
importantly it showed some capability in
answering general questions and these
questions did not need to be present in
the training data this is known as zero
shot learning it's a remarkable feature
and it highlighted the potential of
language models to generalize from their
training data and apply it to arbitrary
tasks they followed this experiment
immediately with gpt2 this time they
used the exact same approach but with a
data set scraped from a large portion of
the web and they used a much larger
network with around 300,000 neurons the
results surprised even the researchers
they tested it on tasks such as reading
comprehension summarization translation
and question answering amazingly it
could translate languages as good as
systems trained only on translation
without any translation specific
training but except for a news cycle
about potential misuse to generate fake
news this development was mostly ignored
even by experts in the field the problem
still was eventually gbt2 still drifted
off into nonsense after many sentences
it couldn't hold coherence or context
for really long periods of time and so
was obviously still a trick right but
the team now understood that this could
be solved simply by making everything
bigger again especially the context
window next they did the same experiment
again but made the network a 100 times
bigger gpt3 had 175 billion connections
and 96 layers and a much longer context
window of around a thousand words this
time they trained it on the entire
common web plus Wikipedia as well as
several book collections again it showed
increased performance across all
measures but one capability really
jumped out once training was complete
you could still teach the network new
things known as in context learning in
the gpt3 paper researchers showed a
simple example where they first gave the
definition of a madeup word gigaro and
then asked it to use that word in a
sentence which it did perfectly this is
known as the wug test and it's a key
milestone in the linguistic development
of children but this was just the tip of
the iceberg the key point is we could
change the behavior of the network
without changing the network weights
that is a frozen Network can learn new
tricks Inc context learning works
because it's leveraging the internal
model of the individual Concepts which
it can combine or compose arbitrarily so
you can think of two layers of learning
a core in weight learning which happens
during training and then a layer of in
context learning which happens during
use or inference many pointed out that
we seem to have stumbled into a new
Computing Paradigm where the computer
operates at the level of thoughts where
a thought is a response to a prompt this
put the programming of these systems in
anyone's hands The Prompt is the program
but in terms of the general public gpt3
still remained relatively unknown to
enable General use they took gpt3 and
shaped Its Behavior to better follow
human instructions with further training
on more examples of good versus bad
human instruction this pushed the
learning pressure Beyond simply next
word and towards next phrasing not only
what to say but how to say it every time
he does something a little closer to
what we want him to do we reinforce him
20 minutes and the pigeon has learned to
Peck the disc to get food known as
instruct GPT which could engage in human
conversations much more effectively and
this became the consumer facing product
chat GPT this kicked off the most
exciting year of experimentation in AI
history as over 100 million people used
this system in public and reported their
results in a fire hose of surprises one
key observation after its release was
its ability to talk to itself and think
out loud a paper was highly shared
showing that simply adding the phrase
think step by step at the end of your
prompt dramatically improved the
performance of Chachi BT because this
this kicked off an iterative Loop where
the subth thoughts were written down
into meaningful chunks allowing it to
follow a chain of reasoning as long as
needed resulting in fewer errors this
led to an explosion of experiments all
building on this idea of selft talk and
then people tried to put these agents
into Virtual Worlds and gave them tasks
and they would learn to use tools to
accomplish this talking to themselves
along the way researchers also applied
this tool use to the real world plugging
language models into external computer
systems through apis allowing them to
make calls place orders and perform
arbitrary tasks and finally we gave them
physical senses through cameras and
actuators in fact every task performed
by computers could now be re-engineered
with an llm at the core of the process I
don't think it's accurate to think of
large language models as a chatbot or
like some kind of a word generator I
think it's a lot more correct to think
about it as the kernel process of an
emerging operating system you have an
equivalent of uh random access memory or
Ram uh which in this case for an llm
would be the context window and you can
imagine this llm trying to page relevant
information in and out of its context
window to perform your task and when
researchers pressed ahead with networks
even 10 times bigger on GPT 4 and Beyond
the trend continued again and today
there is a to build the most capable
intelligent agent of them all the Oracle
humans have always dreamed of and feared
some speculate this moment marks a
unification of the field of AI around a
single Direction instead of specialized
networks focused on specific kinds of
data all researchers pointed to treating
all perceptions as language that is a
series of information bearing
symbols and then training networks on
prediction powered by networks with
self- attention this leads to a more
General system that could be retasked on
any arbitrary narrow problem it seems
that there's something fundamental about
the ability to learn to get better at
predicting future perceptions that is
core to learning in both biological and
artificial neural networks imagination
is a great survival mechanism because it
minimizes surprise and since our actions
are part of our perceptions we also
learn the result of our actions as a
byproduct of this perception prediction
problem so the question now is did we
invent the core of a tool to end all
tools a potential solution to mental
automation which was the original Dream
of computer science not all agree with
this and some are even insulted well
this is glorified autofilm these systems
are designed in such a way that in
principle they can tell us nothing about
language about learning about
intelligence about thought
nothing the idea that it's just sort of
predicting the next word and using
statistics there's a sense in which
that's true but it's not the sense of
Statistics that most people
understand it from the data it figures
out how to extract the meaning of the
sentence and it uses the meaning of the
sentence to predict the next word it
really does understand and that's quite
shocking chomsky's whole view of
language is kind of crazy when you look
back on it because language is about
conveying meaning it's about conveying
stuff well for what it's worth Jeff I've
always thought chumsky was was
completely wrong from my undergraduate
base just and I think sent natural
language processing down the wrong route
for a long time and even the three
Godfathers of deep learning are not on
the same page anymore so linguistic
abilities and fluency are not related to
the ability to
think those are two different things but
people we respect a lot like Yan think
they don't really understand and it's
crucial to um resolve this issue and we
may not be able to come to a consensus
about other issues until we've resolved
that issue I've I've never seen the AI
Community become fragmented um the way
it feels like it's trending right now
and at the root of this divide is a
philosophical question one group
believes these models trick us into
thinking they are smarter than they are
like mirrors that reflect our own
thoughts in ways we didn't anticipate
and the other side believes that if it
looks like thought then it is thought
and so the line between simulating
thought and actual thought is becoming
ever more blurred or perhaps there is no
line this was and still is something
people are struggling to get their heads
around asked her to my office and sat
her down at the keyboard and then she
began to type and of course I looked
over her shoulder to make sure that
everything was operating properly after
two or three interchanges with the with
the machine she turned to me and she
said said would you mind leaving the
womb please and yet she knew as wisen
bom did that Eliza didn't understand a
single word that was being typed into
it you're like my father in some ways
you don't argue with me why do you think
I don't argue with you you're afraid of
me does it please you to think I'm
afraid of you my father's afraid of
everybody my father's afraid of
[Music]
everybody we got the
secret